This is our only chance
we have to take it
we need kong the world needs
him to stop what's coming
and this child she's the only one he'll
communicate with i knew that they had a bond she
had nowhere to go so i made a promise to protect
her and i think that in some way kong did the same
it's godzilla
these are dangerous times godzilla's out there
and he's hurting people and we don't know why
there's something provoking him that we're
not seeing here. I'm of the same opinion.
the myths are real yeah there was a war
and they're the last one standing
kong bows to no one
Welcome back everyone it's charlie this is going
to be my godzilla versus kong trailer video i'll
explain what's going on with the movie there's a
whole bunch of easter eggs here for the classic
version of this the 1962 king kong vs godzilla
film so if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos this is warner
brothers next big movie in their plan for 2021
movies to release all of them on hbo max we'll do
giveaways for subscriptions all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave your favorite
moment from the trailer on the video if you're not
a big fan of the classic godzilla films or king
kong films i know this seems a lot like batman v
superman like make two titans fight who's going to
win and who winds up being the real villain of the
film because it seems like they will eventually
team up similar to the plot of batman v superman
like even though they're fighting here clearly
someone is manipulating godzilla to attack mankind
like you see this big tokyo fight when godzilla
is supposed to be a friend to mankind especially
after the last film saving the planet from king
ghidorah and because we're talking about this
modern franchise of godzilla and king kong films
you go back to kong skull island kong was also a
good character during that so why would they
fight unless they had a version of lex luthor
manipulating both of them to fight and who
winds up being the real villain of the film
there's some rumors about that that'll explain but
the movie itself is coming out march 26th and we
make jokes about batman v superman but the justice
league snyder cut zack snyder also did batman v
superman is also coming out in march but millie
bobby brown and kyle chandler her father are back
from godzilla king of monsters along with a lot
of the monarch characters some of the new ones are
alexander skarsgard the kid from deadpool 2 ezia
gonzalez i don't know exactly what she's going to
be doing during the film but she might be working
with the other organization that i'll explain
in a second rebecca hall seems like another good
character working with alexander skarsgard a sort
of kong expert who's taking care of this little
girl here who has a special connection with kong
they made the joke in the last film though
that the people are essentially the pets of
the titans like she'd be kong's pet not the other
way around even though she's holding up this kong
doll seeming like she's summoning him like a golem
or worshipping him somehow the other really big
thing that everyone's talking about is that kong
got a huge size upgrade he has been working out or
juicing or something like that because normally he
would be way smaller than godzilla like you think
about the actual scale of the titans normally you
think of king kong you think about him climbing
the empire state building but here it looks like
he towers over the city skyline like they're meant
to be about the same size and i think that's
exactly why they made him bigger so that in
this batman v superman matchup that they're
hyping even though it's a bit of a misdirect
they seem like they're relatively evenly matched
because king kong doesn't really have any secret
powers and godzilla is already almost invulnerable
has his atomic breath power from the first film
then from the second film he had that new power
the atomic burst that red power and during this
film he's also supposed to show off another new
power so that's like three special powers to king
kong's zero powers like he can fashion weapons
there in the really cool thing about the weapon
that he does fashion that axe that he has is that
if you can't tell from the fact that it's glowing
in blue just like godzilla when he lights up it's
made from one of his dorsal spikes so i'm assuming
that one of their earlier fights he's able to
damage godzilla one of the spikes falls off then
he uses that to fashion the special weapon for
their next really really big fight which seems
like it's happening in tokyo that's another thing
that they haven't really done in the newer modern
godzilla films is they haven't taken him back to
tokyo in a really really big way but that seems
like a big classic deep cut because normally
that's where he'd be in his films even though
they don't get into it too much during this if
you look at the imdb page you can see that a lot
of people are cast as workers for an organization
called apex and i believe that they're supposed to
be the villains of the film sort of like an evil
version of monarch that's exploiting titans for
profit and for weaponry they kind of got into that
during the last film like they said that people
were trying to harvest titan dna like you have
charles dance's character who's this eco-terrorist
but then there are a lot of other governments
around the world that they were talking about that
want to get their hands on titans to weaponize
them apex is one of the organizations that they're
talking about you see a couple big boss fights
before their big fight too like you see king
kong fighting a couple other titans these flying
snake titans might be the nosuki you also see what
might be the flying bat titan later in the trailer
too but then godzilla kong and the other rumored
actual main villain of the film won't be the only
titans in the film there'll be a bunch of other
ones too because remember there were 17 of them
that they showed off in the last film on that map
the big fight that they have on the aircraft
carriers too is supposed to be an homage to
the classic king kong vs godzilla fight and i know
it's weird that they switched the title like the
classic film is titled king kong vs godzilla why
would they title the modern version of the film
godzilla versus king kong reversing the credits
like why would they give godzilla top billing
it's mostly because their positioning godzilla is
the main character the real main character in this
situation like even though in batman v superman
they're both about the same level of popularity
and superman is basically meant to be a god on
earth but when you think about it the godzilla
films themselves are much more popular than the
king kong film so it just sounds like they plan
to continue with godzilla films and this is
going to be one of the final king kong films
like i'm not expecting to see a third king kong
film with this version of kong so if he continues
within this godzilla universe of new modern films
he just probably shows up in other godzilla films
assuming that they don't wind up fridging one of
these main titans you also think about the last
film too godzilla is already king of the monsters
king of the titans so it's not like kong is going
to become king of the titans or anything like
that this is obviously just the first trailer so
they're not really giving you a lot of the story
they're just giving you some of the highlights
from probably like the first half of the film up
to the first big tokyo fight like when everything
is neon but i think that most of this footage is
really only from like the first part of the film
before you find out what's going on with the real
villains the apex organization so they'll probably
be more of them in the second trailer and maybe
they'll wind up doing the doomsday thing that
they did during the batman v superman trailers
where they actually reveal who the real villain
of the film is going to be so that they can team
up together just like in batman v superman millie
bobby brown's character claims that godzilla is
being manipulated by someone so the evil apex
organization might have some version of the orca
or something else like that they're using to force
godzilla to destroy all these different places
around the planet but just hurting the timeline
a little bit because it's been a while since
we saw that kong skull island movie that takes
place during the 1970s so if they bring back tom
hiddleston's character or reference him in some
way remember that he be in his like late 70s or
early 80s during the events of this film so don't
expect young tom hiddleston to be running around
a whole bunch it kind of seems like this franchise
is turning into millie bobby brown's franchise
just because she seems like a much bigger
character than she was during the first film
but the really big rumor though about the main
villain is that the real villain of the film is
going to wind up being mecca godzilla and that's
who they'll eventually team up to wind up taking
down and apex themselves the evil organization
will be responsible for creating mechagodzilla
and i think it has something to do with them
tying back to that idea of them harvesting titan
dna like harvesting parts of king ghidorah and
using that to create mega godzilla a weapon
against godzilla i think we get a few peaks
of that during the trailer like you see in
the background here this actually looks kind
of like mechagodzilla and then behind this dude
on this display here this might be an apex lab
you see battery charging in this outline of what
looks like mechagodzilla on a readout but everyone
let me know in the comments what do you think
is actually going on because this is clearly a
misdirect and godzilla is a good character and
which new titan from the classic godzilla films
that we haven't seen yet do you think that
they're going to eventually team up to fight
because the movie's coming out march 26th
they'll probably be another trailer sometime
during february and they'll just start releasing
a whole bunch more footage so we'll probably find
out pretty quickly but everyone click here for my
full wandavision episode 3 video in marvel easter
eggs and click here for my brand new thor 4 teaser
and learn about what's going on during that film
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next video!